Một thống của quay nè với một bài thống của mình một chứ biết
một đêm năm nay sẽ làm một trong những dưới rãn khó khăn nhất với quay nè
khi mang ngày đăng tích chữ hàng chơi mấy bai không về lái, cho các đợt tình công mới.
Ông nhấn mạnh, ước tiên hàng đầu của kế và bảo vệ không phát và cùng cố năng lực phòng không tận các thành phố tìm tuyến.
Ô quay nè hiện đánh chín khai kế hoạc tăng cửa phịt thống lãnh trạng qua vê.
Bây giờ tải kê sân và các khu vực miền đông.
Đông thời tìm kiến muòn tài chính đề nhập khẩu khi đóc,
bởi kinh phí dự kiến và khoảng 2 tìm đúng là Mỹ.
Chúng kiến đó, các đợt tình công mới của ngay đã khiến nhiều khu vực miền.
Bộ quay nè phải áp dọc lịch các địa lôn phían.
Dời chức năng lượng cho biết, nè đang thay đổi chính phật chuyển sang các cuộc tấn công kéo sài.
Nếu như trước đây, một tiêu của mắt, các bạn là người ra tình chẳng mất địa chỉ dọc trong thời gian ngắn.
Thì năm nay, họ tập trung tấn công kéo sài.
Nhanh làm suy kiện dân hệ thống năng lượng của quay nè.